president-elect joe biden says the worst
of the pandemic
is still to come he's asking americans
to be ready for what's likely to be
a difficult winter nicole killian is in
wilmington delaware covering the biden
transition and nicole the inauguration
is four weeks from today
we understand he's made another cabinet
choice
that's right jamie this morning
president-elect biden is officially
introducing connecticut schools chief
miguel
cardona as his new education secretary
one of his first tests will be reopening
school
safely in the midst of the pandemic
our darkest days in the battle against
covet
are ahead of us not behind us
president-elect joe biden put it
straight to the american people
the pandemic could claim tens of
thousands more lives in the months to
come
vaccine won't be able to stop that
so we'll still have to remain vigilant
the president-elect also issued a stark
warning over a massive cyber breach
against multiple
government agencies this attack
constitutes a
grave risk to our national security
he slammed president trump for
downplaying the hack
and pressed him to hold those
responsible accountable suggesting as
others in the administration have
that it was the work of russia this
assault happened on
donald trump's watch when he wasn't
watching
but rest assured that even if he does
not take it seriously i
will with less than a month until his
inauguration
mr biden continues to build his team
there's not an obvious choice in my mind
while he has yet to name an attorney
general he is moving forward with his
pick for education secretary
connecticut education commissioner
miguel cardona is a former public school
teacher
and the third latino nominated to the
cabinet
this is the official this is the ass
brother
and in california another historic
selection
governor gavin newsom appointed his
secretary of state alex padilla to fill
vice president-elect kamala harris's
senate seat
making him the state's first latino
senator i'm honored man
and i'm humbled
the vice president-elect congratulated
padilla
calling him a champion and a dear friend
as for mr biden's remaining cabinet
nominations he said he's still
working through them and could have more
announcements between now
and the new year vlad all right nicole
thank you very much